noah Richler journalist author and
podcaster welcome to the property oh
thanks for having me fear and loathing
on the campaign trail of fear and
loathing of course very well-known
expression why did you choose that as
the title well you know it was actually
its homage to hunter s thompson of
course who was such a good an original
political writer and who followed what I
think his book came out about 44 years
ago but he used the title more than
months himself and so I felt that it was
a kind of shortcut and would tell them
eat people immediately something of the
tone of the book you'll be disappointed
if you're looking for great druggy
Hayes's it's not that and I'm a little
disappointed you'd say hang on are you
comparing yourself to Robert Redford the
candidate no so it's it's there's a
little tribute being page and it's
acknowledged inside with an epigraph
from Hunter Thompson as well now you are
a creative person and politics and
creativity don't necessarily go hand in
hand why did you choose to enter the
fray as it were well I was basically
just fed up as so many people were and
with Harper and the kind of perversion
of Canadian government in the last four
years of a conservative regime so I
think my wife knew that I've been
mulling it for a while and I think of my
books as political even when they about
things like Canada through his story
tellers as my first book is my country
what's yours was I think of them as
political and but also felt it was time
to participate throw my hat in the ring
and I was very interested that for my
last book which is a book about how we
talked ourselves into and out of
Afghanistan how people were afraid to
speak up so i imagine that just putting
yourself forward and saying it's time
for change and furthermore I I believe
the change might actually be the third
party the NDP was I think worthwhile and
it felt like I was elevating the
argument and I hoped you know doing that
in spite of your connection with with
political subjects I get the impression
from reading the book that you entered
this and were surprised at how it
actually runs sure I know I was
something I was a real innocent you know
I think kids in high school who study
these things need more than I did and
but that innocence served me well
I'm there's a certain grassroots
tradition in the NDP as it is I was also
running in a campaign where little was
expected of me and so weather is less
there was an opportunity for that
creativity you were talking about and it
was urgent for me because I was joining
the game very late I didn't have time to
knock on every door in the riding and so
I needed to reach people some other way
and so the social media campaign that I
was new was going to be a part of my
effort was all the more vital and almost
by chance I ran into this fantastic
videographer who helped me out with that
a guy called Nick denboer who it turned
out did a lot of stuff for Conan O'Brien
and then later for Vice magazine and he
was able for instance to insert me into
probably what was the most popular video
of any parties would way in which justin
trudeau now the Prime Minister is
standing unable to get anywhere on an
escalator and what we did in our video
we made several of them some were quite
straightforward others used humor to
make a point and to get people that
might not have been interested in NDP
message to read it we inserted me into
that of those frames so I pass Justin
Trudeau on the escalator baffled that
this man is unable to get to the top and
use that as a way of making the case for
the NDP and that irritated the little so
much that newspapers across the land
referred scarless Facebook and Twitter
posts that I'd written and and in the
end you were obliged for better or worse
to withdraw it right what would the I
did withdraw the second video there was
another one that we were Democrat at the
engine our targets so there was one that
took on Justin Trudeau and other took on
Harper and and used footage from the
national interview that Peter Mansbridge
at done with Stephen Harper in front of
the buildings of Parliament and it's
actually remarkably clever and because
what happens is that this figure appears
out of the law and you don't see who it
is and a hand comes over and removes the
Canada lapel pin from harper's suit and
then gives his seat an almighty kick and
sends him flying out of the picture and
then it turns out to be me and i sit
down i explained to peter mansbridge why
in fact the NDP is the party of change
and we had good legal grounds for doing
this but by the time this the CBC which
is you know
I suppose credible initiative on their
part sent a letter threatening legal
action to take it down we had a case
there was no case that seeps he had but
the NDP did actually remove it and what
and I put that account in the book not
to grandstand in any way but because to
me it was a symptom of a campaign that
was going awry where the leaders were
losing confidence and they were just so
cowed at that point that they gave in at
one point in the book you mentioned and
I've heard this regarding other
campaigns and people who enter for the
first time that there are no guidelines
there's no book saying you know this is
the way it works it's like you're pretty
much as a new candidate left on your own
device absolutely that and that really
did surprise me I thought you know I'd
get this fat book telling me whom to
hire and why I should what kind of
qualities I should be looking for these
people in these positions and how much
money's arrays and what I was expected
to do a week 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 know that
and I still wonder why that so is that
because the spin doctors these
fantastically undemocratic people that
stand behind every party's effort to get
in government people who regard it as
their job like Kevin Spacey in the house
of cards or Oscar gamble and Britain to
sort of manipulate public and make the
public believe that they want to serve a
certain outcome maybe they these people
feel that they don't want to put any of
their secrets down maybe by just telling
you what to look for this somehow handy
information to another party that's the
mindset you know that I learned about
towards the end and in the beginning my
campaign was carried by this fantastic
tide of extraordinary goodwill volunteer
is given their time and money and then
you kind of slam up against the wall of
the party operatives that's that's the
less inspiring part of politics well
Noah Richler one of the things that I
also found interesting was a comment
made to you fairly early on saying
politics is not about ideas it's about
winning yes so that was a comment made
by one of your co ferrer by a CBC
political reporter early decent guy
James cut more it was in Ottawa for a
time and he was positively distressed at
the idea of the
his friend might run and he get you know
he said nice note gave good advice but I
did it anyway but he was saying you know
they're not gonna be in Sidon your ideas
and he was right no I had this fantasy
that somebody would call from you know
Ottawa saying no we got a little fix
here on in the cultural realm or in
foreign policy what do you think of
course that was never going to happen
it's too intense everybody's in a cocoon
during a campaign well this in turn also
a case where the the leaders aren't of
any party not just the NDP but any party
really aren't all that interested in the
little guys and our little people in the
party the back benchers or the back
benchers just you know be quiet yeah and
someone else I should try to raise the
horror of the backbench to me and I sort
of play with that or these little
fantasy sequences in the book that are
actually quite true in which I imagine
myself to a politician of in positions
of less and less power but ya know they
don't have and I'm actually sympathetic
I mean in a way running a campaign from
the National point of view is a
potentially enormous human resources
problem and I'm sure you go to work
every day thinking please save me from
some further embarrassing action by you
know the candidate in lethbridge or
wherever you know and when it came my
turn to be the potentially embarrassing
thing they were actually recently they
were quite supportive but they did not
you know I said to them look okay at
that point I was the facebook twitter
post being used against me I said look
I've got a column here written it we can
publish it it says I'm sorry i'm not
saying sorry let's move it on and that
was actually fairly recent i think at
some other political candidate will do
that because what we've learned from
Trump in America is that the people
don't really listen to all these efforts
by media especially to embarrass
candidates they're actually put off by
that those ordinary rites of passage
well no original er what did you learn
about politics I mean eventually you did
not win your seat in politics as was
more or less expected what did you learn
about politics I learned that you have
to believe you can win that it's not
even a rational to believe you you can
win you're leading all these people I've
spoke of the extraordinary tired of
goodwill of volunteers how can you do
that if you think you're going to lose
then effectively you're almost acting in
bad faith or lying
I learned that as the candidate you're
not the boss you're part of this
incredible enterprise and that brings a
smile to my face even now because I was
surrounded by people who knew more than
me and I suppose I learned that it works
and it's a good thing I mean the book
really helped me sort out these
conflicted emotions and I felt
preposterous Lee disappointed after i
lost i took it far too personally and i
knew it was silly to do so but that's
how it felt but the book made me
understand what a privilege it is to
have a democracy and what good work
people do there's one of the best things
i did my life so you're not cynical at
all about some of the things that came
across like no no another example you
know you have to hate your opponent and
you have to that's not about others yeah
and I'm not never gonna be that fellow
and perhaps I was saved from something
by losing though i think i would have
probably made a virtue of it had I 12
but I don't you know I think that we
evolve constantly and we'll learn how to
deal with the you know as I say pseudo
house of cards spin doctors that think
they know best and will you know whether
it's a constantly evolving craft or say
I'd say more than art or science and the
bottom line is it's driven by people
volunteering and buying people willing
to listen to you at the door Susan what
about the message from the inside as
opposed to the message the public gets
on the outside what you mean by that
well the experience of being on the
inside and and what people see on the
outside in terms of you know I was
actually stunned when I said about
writing this book and I did not mean to
write a book I didn't enter politics to
do this in fact I told the first person
who asked me if I could write a book
that there was no way I could do it only
been in the game for five months and
then it came very easily and it was
enormous fun to write this book and what
it is is a kind of a narrative journey
almost an oval like narrative journey of
what it means to be a candidate and that
was those great material for that but
it's also an exercise in political
transparency it's a I was stunned that
there was no
count of a political campaign from the
ground the only memoirs we have our by
people who are in power or vying for
power i'm not that i lost i was one of
the 1454 people that did not win last
year but what you have here is a
completely true documented I hope
entertaining account that offers up a
example of that transparency that
politicians always say they are after
but rarely an act what about yourself no
Richler what did you learn about
yourself before and after this well it
may not sound like this is true but I
learned to write more simply you know
I'll urged speaking shorter sentences
and and communicate a little bit better
I think it taught the people that love
me the most around me that in fact I'm
okay they were very worried about how
it'd be at the door would I be able to
engage the public that was not an issue
for me and provides me some great
memories and probably that I'm on the
one hand a fella that still DC has ideas
to contribute to the political sphere
but on the other probably rightfully
back in the old job Noah Richler thank
you very much for this and graduation on
an interesting book and entertaining as
well great thank you Mark